[horn sounding]
[horns sounding]
Caroline Aghajanian: On the season
finale of "Travel Dares,"
Nico Reyes: I'm taking Caroline to learn
how to play the Swiss alphorn.
[horn sounding]
Aj Caldwell: And I'm taking Caroline
to learn how to make Swiss cowbells.
[bell ringing]
Caroline: Come
join us on our adventures
on this episode of "Travel Dares."
Caroline: This is "Travel Dares,"
the show where we do daring
activities all over Europe
empowered by my Marriott
Bonvoy Boundless card.
We've been to seven amazing cities so far,
and we're ending our journey
in Lucerne, Switzerland.
Aj: To thank you for
taking us all over Europe,
me and Nico are taking
you on two special dares.
Caroline: Yes! That's a lot
of time in the blindfold,
but I'm super excited.
Nico: We're gonna start
off with my dare first,
the better dare.
Here's your clue.
Caroline: Did you hear
that? The better dare.
Aj: Yeah, we're saving the
best for last, it's fine.
Caroline: We're going back to school!
We were just in Cambridge, Nico.
Nico: Listen, we all know
that these clues mean nothing.
[all laughing]
Caroline: My first instinct
is to think of, like, a book.
A textbook? But no, it has
something to do with music notes.
Music notes!
I'm nervous!
Nico: Towards this way.
Aj: All right,
we're gonna go this way, into the grass.
Caroline: Oh, God.
Nico: Now it's a little bit easier.
Caroline: It's very uneven.
You guys, I'm really overwhelmed.
Do I take off my blindfold?
Nico: No! Not yet!
Caroline: Oh, my God, OK.
[horn sounds]
[Caroline screams]
Oh, my God, oh, my God!
[all laughing]
Nico: Today we're gonna learn
how to play the Swiss alphorn.
Caroline: Oh, my God.
Nico: Look at this thing.
Caroline: That's such a long horn!
Caroline: Got it!
Nico: All right, let's go.
Caroline: I feel like this is something
you only see in movies.
Aj: I know!
Caroline: All right,
now, how do we do this?
Nico: OK, guys. There are
three things that we gotta do.
First, we gotta figure out
how to play this thing.
Second, we're gonna figure
out how to hold these notes,
and third is that we're gonna figure out
how we can play all together
like a little Swiss alphorn band.
Think you guys can handle all that?
Aj: Oh, I can handle it.
Caroline: Yeah, definitely.
Nico: I'm talking as if
I've played this thing
my whole life.
Anique: Hi, guys, my name is Anique,
and I'm the translator of Willi.
He plays the alphorn professional,
and he's gonna show you guys
how to play the alphorn.
[horn sounds]
Nico: I love this song.
Caroline: There's so many notes.
Aj: I know!
Caroline: Good job, Willi.
[mouthpiece toots]
[horn toots]
Nico: Wow! You did it, Aj!
Aj: I got it!
Nico: Everyone gets a
hat when they do good.
Oh, my God!
Willi: Very good.
[horn squeaks]
[Nico laughs]
Nico: Hoo!
[all laughing]
That was me, it wasn't the horn.
[horn sounding]
[all cheering]
[mouthpiece toots]
[laughs]
[horn sounding]
Nico: Yay!
Aj: Yes! That's so good!
Caroline: I literally have to, like,
[blows raspberries] in there.
[horns sound]
[squeals]
Nico: That sounded pretty good.
Caroline: That was amazing!
Nico: OK, so we know how to play them now.
Now we just have to figure
out how to hold a tone.
OK, so here's a little challenge.
Let's try to do low, medium, high notes.
Aj, you start.
Aj: All right.
[clears throat]
[exhales]
Aj: Here we go.
[horn sounding weakly]
I forgot how to do this!
Nico: Are you sure you played the trumpet?
Were you lying?
Aj: No, I did not play the
trumpet, I played the saxophone.
[horn sounding]
Aj: Wasn't fair!
Caroline: That was great!
Nico: I still sound a little busted, but.
Caroline: That was good.
[horn trumpeting]
[laughing]
Can I redo the high one?
Aj: I don't understand!
[playing up the scale]
Nico: Smooth!
Aj: That's smooth!
Nico! Yes!
Aj: Whoa!
Caroline: I'ma pass out.
Aj: That's it!
Nico: It's time for our
big band performance.
I'm really nervous.
Caroline: Yeah, it's the moment of truth.
Nico: It's the moment of truth, let's see
if we retained any knowledge today.
OK. All right.
Caroline: Let's do it.
Nico: Let's break it down.
[horns hooting rhythmically]
[horns bellowing]
[cheering]
[laughing]
Caroline: That was really good.
Nico: Amazing. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you,
sheep, thank you, goats.
Caroline: I am, like,
really peaceful right now,
so just leave me here.
Did you guys hear that?
Encore?
All: Encore! Encore!
Encore! Here we go!
[horns bellowing]
Aj: All right, Caroline, I
know you had a good time,
but are you ready to
have an even better time
with my day?
Caroline: Yes! Ooh.
OK, are we, like, redoing
a dare or something?
Aj: I don't know.
Nico: Think about it.
Caroline: I'm, like, thinking
over all of the dares.
We've done a lot of dares.
Nico: We've done a lot of dares.
Caroline: I feel like
we're gonna be doing a dare
that we've already done but, like,
amp it up, like, times 100.
Aj: Slide over.
Nico: Right here.
Caroline: OK, all right.
Aj: Are you ready, Caroline?
Caroline: Yep.
[bell ringing]
[screams]
[laughing]
Caroline: What is this?
Aj: Today we're learning
how to make cowbells!
Caroline: Oh, my God, wow!
Wait, that thing is huge!
Can I try?
Aj: Yeah.
[bell ringing]
Caroline: Oh, my God, it's heavy.
Caroline: Nice to meet you.
Olivia Rast: Nice to meet you, I'm Olivia.
Caroline: Olivia, so nice to meet you.
What is the first step?
Olivia: So, first, they have
to fill this form with sand.
Caroline: So, this. Ooh, this is heavy.
And right here.
Ooh, that feels good.
It's a nice chunk of cold sand.
More sand. Well, all right.
Oh!
[machine whirring]
[Caroline screams]
Nico: I feel like these
steps are a little scary,
but she's confidently doing them.
Caroline: Who would have known I had
these bell-making skills?
Aj knew, for sure.
Olivia: These are the forms.
Nico: Oh, they're flowers.
Olivia: To put on the stamps.
So, they have all the letters,
so, if you, as a customer you have a wish,
they can write everything
you want into the bell.
Caroline: One, two, and.
Yeah! We finally got it.
Nico: OK.
Caroline: Come take a
look at my masterpiece.
Nico: Let's inspect it.
Olivia: Wow.
Aj: Hmm.
Nico: I don't even know
what I'm looking for,
but it looks right.
Caroline: Ah!
Aj: Whoa!
Caroline: Look, they're
about to make my bell!
Nico: Oh, my God.
Caroline: Yay!
Nico: Whoa!
Olivia: At this place, they
are making the very special,
valuable cowbells.
In Switzerland, we make,
like, presents for weddings
or birthdays or special events.
And here you can see how this
family creates the bells.
It's a family tradition,
and you can make your own cowbells
with customized design with letters.
Caroline: Oh, I know
my bell when I see her.
There she is!
Ooh, this is my bell!
And she's a heavy one.
Come on! Whoo!
She's beautiful.
Next step, polishing station.
I'm just gonna brush the bell a little.
Oh, my God, this is, like, real gold.
It's looking really good.
Look, guys!
Look at it.
How does it look?
Nico: Wow, it's so shiny.
Aj: It looks good.
Caroline: It's my little bell.
Aj: The stamps you put
in came out really well.
Nico: It looks great, it looks great.
Caroline: Thank you, thank you.
Now it's the moment of
truth. How does it sound?
Nico: OK, all right.
[bell ringing]
Nico: It sounds like a bell.
Aj: Sounds like a cowbell.
Nico: A cowbell!
Caroline: It's beautiful. I'm so proud.
I got my bell, I got my belt.
I don't know how I'm gonna
fit it into my luggage.
Nico: It's gonna make it so heavy.
Caroline: Perfect! Yay!
Can you grab my bell?
Nico: Let's go.
Caroline: I actually had so much fun
on this dare. Thank you.
Nico: Me too.
Aj: I'm glad you guys enjoyed it,
but I do have one more surprise...
a double dare.
Nico: Another dare?
Caroline: What?
Aj: Another dare for the both of you.
Nico: What, now?
Aj: Blindfold up!
Caroline: Wait, I'm
actually kind of excited.
Nico: I'm nervous, I
was not in on this one.
Aj: Here we go, I got
you. All right, you ready?
Caroline: Oh, good. OK, this way.
Caroline: Here's the thing,
you planned this surprise,
you don't even give us a clue.
Nico: We can't have a clue?
Caroline: We don't have a clue.
Aj: No clues, no clues.
Nico: Oh, my God.
Caroline: Nothing at all.
Aj: Just gonna show up and enjoy.
Caroline and Nico will never guess
the surprise I have planned for them.
Down the hill, a little slower,
Nico, Caroline's behind you.
Nico: OK.
Caroline: Oh, my God,
oh, my God, oh, my God.
Aj: OK, perfect.
Caroline: Oh, my God.
Aj: Now take off your blindfolds,
'cause we're meeting Swiss cows.
[screaming]
[laughing]
[bells jingling]
Caroline: Oh, my God.
Hi.
Nico: They're so big.
Nico: I'm Nico. Oh, caress.
Olivia: The cowbells are very important
because usually the cows are
by themselves in the mountains
and so you can hear them.
You can hear where your herd is,
and you don't have to go and find them
because you know where they are.
Caroline: I've never touched a cow before.
You're so cute.
Aj, this is the best surprise ever.
Oh, my God.
Aj: I knew you guys would love it.
Nico: This is super fun.
I do love cows, cows
are my favorite animal.
Caroline: Bye.
Nico: Bye, ladies, it was a
pleasure meeting all of you.
Caroline: You're so cute, bye-bye.
Aj: We've enjoyed our time here.
Aj: Bye!
Caroline: You guys, Switzerland
has been so amazing,
so beautiful, people are so nice.
Lucerne is such, like, a cute,
small, quaint little town.
Kinda like this hotel.
Aj: And look at this
spread. It looks so good.
Nico: So good.
Caroline: Starving.
Nico: Me too.
Caroline: Moment of truth.
My final rating, and I
get two this time, so,
Nico, you start, yeah.
Nico: I'll go first.
I didn't know what to expect
when you went up there
with that Swiss alphorn.
It is not an easy thing to
play, to pick up, to learn,
but you were so passionate and determined
to learn all those tones,
so I think I have to give you
a five-star rating.
Caroline: Yes! Yes!
Nico: You even impressed Willi,
our teacher!
Caroline: Oh, my gosh.
And Aj?
Aj: All right, so, Caroline,
for the cowbell making,
you were so excited to do it.
You were super involved at
every step of the process,
and I'm really proud of the
way that your bell came out.
So for that, you're getting another
five out of five stars.
Nico: 10 stars!
Caroline: 10 stars!
Double fives, you guys.
You guys, we've done
so many amazing things,
went to so many beautiful places,
but I gotta know, do you
have a favorite dare?
Aj and Nico: Ooh.
Aj: Oh, I do.
Nico: You do?
Aj: Yeah, the waterslide in Austria.
Nico: Ooh, fun.
Caroline: Oh, my gosh, that was amazing.
That was such a thrill.
Aj: I loved it.
Nico: I definitely think my favorite
was the soap-making in Marseille.
I wasn't expecting the process
to be as hard as it was,
but everything smelled so good
and it was so fun to cut
it all up. It was awesome.
Caroline: I have to say,
my favorite is absolutely
the Swiss alphorn.
It was amazing.
I had such an incredible time.
It was gonna be the water bikes in Naples,
but the horn took it away.
Loved it.
Nico: Yeah, she's gonna move here
to become a Swiss
alphorn player, for sure.
Aj: I believe it.
Caroline: Just leave me
on top of that mountain.
Guys, what a way to end our trip.
I'm really gonna miss you.
Nico: We're gonna miss you, too.
Aj: But hopefully we can do it again soon.
Caroline: Yes! Cheers to that!
Nico: Cheers!
Caroline: Yay, whoops!
Drink it fast.